m
et bien bonjour diagonale l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs vous
jouerez loi bonjour stéphane tombe sur
nous tous tôt ce matin pour donc un
compte rendu du 3 à sarajevo que
démarrer en trombe mais garde hier donc
oui démarrage du tournoi hier donc
laissé des émissions diagonale spécial
et exceptionnel puisque tous les matins
nous vous ferons un compte rendu de ce
tournoi de sarajevo donc un superbe
catégorie 19 c pa catégorie 19 alors la
catégorie que tu peux nous rappeler ce
que 6ème catégorie
oui la catégorie du tournoi c'est en
fait c'est représentatif de la moyenne
de l'eau des joueurs c'est à dire que
c'est par tranche de 25 points alors je
me rappelle qu'à 2500 on est en
catégorie 10 si je ne dis pas de bêtises
entre 2500 et de 1525 c'est une
catégorie 10 entre 2525 et 557 une 11 et
ainsi de suite
on monte on monte et là on est dans un
tournoi du moyenne lots remarquables
puisqu'on arrive avec la théorie 19 je
n'ai pas calculer exactement quel 16e
des joueurs mais c'est un tournoi très
très fort avec bien entendu des stars
alors wagon joueurs on va détailler en
attendant tout à fait détaillé
maintenant on va on va présenter ce
tournoi donc sarajevo tournage en 2000
donc avec garry kasparov
donc ça c'est quand même la caution
quand il est là c'est toujours un ton à
suivre oui garry kasparov on ne le
présente plus voilà
nigel short donc anglais qui revient de
peu dans les tournants parce qu'on n'a
pas vu récemment dans les grands
tournois il était pavée casey était
palmarès donc
il est toujours dans les dix premiers
mondiaux mais
il n'était pas invité e
oui alors là on est en train de
commenter en images en direct le
classement du tournoi
donc bon non ouais on va là on va leur
prendre à le reprendre en fait
aujourd'hui c'est une première il y a
des encore des imperfections mais sonné
c'est pas grave donc garry kasparov
continue on va présenter les joueurs
nigel short donc l'anglais
donc qui revient dans un tournoi de top
niveau alexei shirov donc il a qui
revient donc à près d une très belle
performance à monaco et au grand prix du
sénat oh il ne revient pas et c'est
shirov est en forme et en pleine forme
en ce moment il fait des très belles
performances c'est clair et ici il fait
partie des favoris probable de ce
tournoi est favori et puis en plus
peut-être les traits encore plus qu'on
monte contre caspar ans depuis que
grespach enfin annoncer son match contre
krainik siro devait jouer comme kasparov
ils se sont peut-être les et il a
peut-être vraiment une dent spéciale
contre lui oui alors je pense que dans
ce tournoi il ya voilà il ya plusieurs
choses à voir
il ya plusieurs joueurs qui ont des
dents contre kasparov nokia shirov
éventuellement mais il ya surtout sert
qu'à limoges spéciale le joueur d un des
joueurs les moins forts de ce format qui
est quand même encore un très très fort
puisqu'il ya 2660 et des poussières
c'est donc un très bon joueur ex
arméniens qui est maintenant que j'ai
poste le maquis et qui lui a carrément
écrit une lettre ouverte contre garry
kasparov en expliquant à tous que garry
kasparov a été humainement incorrect
tout simplement une lettre une grande
lettre ouverte qui s'étale sur plusieurs
pages ça c'est suite aux championnats du
monde de las vegas ou kasparov disait
que les joueurs s'étaient les touristes
voilà c'est exactement ça donc climat
très tendu entre kasparov et shirov mais
surtout entre kasparov et neuf spéciales
donc ça ça va être les parties choc
attendu mais il y avait un amant ya
quand même dans ce tournoi un élément
très intéressant qui n'est pas habituel
qui n'est pas habituel oui mais on va y
venir on va y venir va y venir donc on
continue par le par les joueurs de gary
kasparov nigel short avec ses chers on a
commenté michael adams donc on retrouve
les deux derniers grands prix du devon
alto en fait puisque adams avait gagné
le grand prix de bordeaux donc adamski
en bonne forme aussi donc il va faire en
sûrement un très bon tournoi
on retrouve ensuite alexander morozevich
le fameux russe toujours un peu
énigmatique parce qu'il n'a pas encore
joué beaucoup de tournois top niveau il
un âge où et quand même
deux ou trois ans maintenant mais il a
il a bien confirmé son placement et il
est maintenant 4e joueur mondial
ou disons qu'il est très énigmatique
parce qu'ils ne parlent pas ils ne
donnent aucune interview il est très
très secret très mystérieux donc
effectivement c'est effectivement c
c'est un joueur c'est un joueur
intéressant et très très donc voilà on
the beach très mystérieux très très
secret et c'est là contre donc il ya
yvan sokolov génie bas relief et
vesselin topalov qui sont très forts
mira gourévitch le fameux joueur belge
donc naturalisé belge
oui alors quelques quelques ennuis
techniques dans cette
alors dire de diagonale spécial sa peau
alors alexander morozevich alain bien
n'a parlé ensuite donc là c'est la
surprise donc tu voulais parler oui
c'est ça la surprise dont je voulais
parler c'est à dire que c'est une
première actuellement dans un tournoi
dans une catégorie plus de quinze je
pense qu'il n'a jamais eu d'aussi fort
il avait joué déjà un catégorie 15 en
france à enghien les bains
c'est notre star hexagonale le jeune
etienne bacrot qui joue ici le pour la
première fois un tournoi d'une super
catégorie un super tournoi
kasparov et tous les autres très très
fort joie alors pour avancer dans cette
émission
après la présentation des joueurs on a
vu à peu près à peu près tout le monde
hein il manque donc yvan sokolov cd a
déjà cité
quand on connaît des ennuis techniques
un bon mélange ce n'est pas grave
puisqu'on va y suis très fier de la cité
sous call pareil j'ai cité comme moi
j'ai oublié puisqu'on va passer au
tirage au sort en mai de l'an passé au
tirage au sort la première le tirage au
sort est un moment très important
puisque c'est après ça on saura qui a
quelques couleurs contre qui puisque
dans un tournoi fermé tout le monde
rencontre tout le monde donc on saura
quelle couleur en a et surtout quand on
joue les adversaires de choix
c'est dire que si on va finir par
kasparov shirov et adams il vaut mieux
commencer par marquer les points dès le
début oui en tout cas ça semble un plan
de jeu raisonnable si on joue ces trois
premiers ces trois premiers joueurs c3
très fort joueur en début de tournoi on
peut calmer le jeu joué solide pour
essayer de marquer les points sur la fin
donc le tirage au sort est un moment
très très important ici à diagonale
spécial sarajevo on va s'intéresser
principalement à la performance
détiennent bacrot et donc tirage au sort
pour etienne bacrot
un peu délicat un peu délicat puisque la
première en huit ans que dans contre le
king garry kasparov ce qui est jamais un
très bon démarrage et en plus avec les
pièces noires et en plus avec quelle
piste donc ça c'est un très très lourd
handicap puisqu'on sait que kasparov
quand ils vont un joueur nouveaux
arrivés dans ce dans ces tournois on
peut les appeler comme ça c'est ces
tournois avec ses joueurs mais il voit
un petit nouveau qui arrive
il a une seule envie c'est de l'exploser
de le legato miser dans le calme et
voilà il a envie de gagner une partie
rapidement et très efficacement donc
c'est exactement ce qui ce qui s'est
passé malheureusement
enfin ce qu'on verra donc etienne bacrot
une partie très très difficile à gérer
avec avec les noirs comptent garry
kasparov
ouais je vais sinon il y avait d'autres
affrontements très intéressant mais hier
d'autres affrontements très intéressant
puisqu'on retrouvait alors d'abord un
match entre les deux nous c'est nous
deux nos deux récents vainqueurs de
deux grands prix du sénat et du grand
prix de bordeaux alexei shirov rencontré
michael adams est un choc
c'était le deuxième match le plus
intéressant le numéro 4 contre le numéro
7 mondial en tout cas au classement réel
pas au classement intermédiaire un très
très beau match entre deux très très
fort joueur on reviendra sur la saleté à
la fin je pense qu'on va tout de suite
passé à notre première rubrique stéphane
oui la première rubrique donc qui sont
les parties enfin les positions clés les
positions clés si on peut envoyer la
première brique
voilà donc voilà les positions clés de
la journée
voilà très bien donc si on peut montrer
maintenant l'échiquier sur sur la
totalité de l'écran on va donc pouvoir
la partie entre gary kasparov et etienne
bacrot parti qui s'est déroulé dans une
partie une écossaise est loin oui tout à
fait unique hausse est donc la
spécialité de garry kasparov
alors j'attends de voir voila voila
c'est l'échiquier sur le temps plein
écran
donc 4 5 avec ses six des 4 puis on
prend des quatre car il prend des quatre
cavaliers m6 car il prend ses 6 et des
princes et six en lacets on est tombé
dans une variante écossaise est oui
alors effectivement on y est tombé
depuis quelques coups déjà puisqu'on
était très très vite alors c'est normal
qu'on est vite puisque le flash new york
une demi heure ici l'ouverture est déjà
connue on l'a déjà nalité dans des gones
al donc on va pas revenir dessus
on va continuer au 5 da nau cette dame
eu deux cavaliers des 5 c 4
il me semble alors qu'on avait analysé
ça déjà dans une diagonale avril 99 oui
tout à fait et ce par aof karpov
d'ailleurs on a même vu une partie de je
crois de moreau et beach sur cette
variante ne semble oui contre x y ou
d'un truc sillonne donc nous avons déjà
commenté cette ouverture vous pouvez
vous référer à la partie moreau duty
youn dans les différents diagonale de
toute façon pour en savoir plus donc
voici fois-ci s'il coule le pian b3 pour
consolider g6 donc là c'est tout à fait
standard
l'idée donc d' etienne bacrot dans cette
partie qui l'oppose à garry kasparov et
de mettre la pression sur le pion aux 5
avec tout simplement fou j'ai cette
suite petit rock est ensuite amené une
tour sur la caso vite donc grosse
pression sur le pion aux 5 suivi
éventuellement par lexis voilà alors un
petit rappel rapide sur les enjeux de
cette position si les bleus arrivent à
tenir le centre et à sortir leur pièce
ils vont être mieux puisque les noirs
ont des pions faibles ils ont des pions
doubler ici en c7 et c6 par contre les
noirs ont une avance de développement
c'est indéniable ils ont sorti deux
pièces mineurs et la dame
les banques ont sorti kadam donc voilà
si noir il va tout faire exploser à
prendre l'option de 5 c les noirs qui
auront remporté le succès de l'ouverture
f4 la dame b 4 échecs compatit pic joué
par etienne bacrot très très atypique
peut-être là il a fait un choix donc
déjà peut-être on peut
discutable c'est tout à fait jouable bon
il y avait je crois qu'il me semble que
sais-je est simple le principal dans
cette position mais kasparov l'avaient
réfutée contre timan autour mode veille
kenzy donc ici de toute façon c'est très
très dur de jouer souhaitons kasparov
mais qu'est ce qui n'est pas difficile
de contrôler kasparov quand il joue le 4
pour etienne c'est délicat puisque 4,5
et une de ses suites les plus solides ce
qui connaît le mieux
je veux une sicilienne contre kasparov
quand on n'est pas complètement au point
c'est impossible tout simplement oui
donc c'est très très difficile avec les
noirs de jouer contre garry kasparov et
c'est vraiment difficile on peut c'est
dommage 3 tienne puisque c'est la
première ronde du tournoi
il n'est pas encore très chaud il est un
peu dans les starting blocks alors que
l'autre il est toujours là votre gary
kasparov il est chaud dès le début il
est toujours là et puis vient de jouer
linares il est prêt à bondir il ya la
ville et dans la suite des tournois là
pour etienne c'est son premier grand
tournoi aussi oublier ça oui il y avait
son match contre karpov avons où il a
fait deux mois et en partie longue
oui donc il a vu - ils apprenent ont
fait beaucoup de parties d'entraînement
mais là il ya toute la pression du
tournoi du top niveau qui s'ajoute à la
pression de kasparov qui s'ajoute au
fait qu'il est noir et ça commence à
faire beaucoup alors on va regarder ce
qui s'est passé pour moi cette partie
résume très bien le terme petit bras
petit moi non je pense qu'on peut dire
ça c'est à dire que mon fou des dos
d'âne des six etienne a cherché à jouer
trop solide il a été prononcé trop
impressionné par son adversaire dames 4
déc l'option ccap donc attaque le
cavalier en d5 est ici un coup de je ne
connaissais pas c'est le coup fcf 5 très
intéressant puisque ça permet donc la
prise en place en mai après la prise en
passant en jour et 3,8 en 9 sets on
menace ray avec la tour à 8 de venir sur
cette case au 8è la base du roi et de
clous et la davrays la dame ayant
récupéré le pion et fils avec le
cavalier probablement une bonne position
et une belle position ici d'un f3 joué
rapidement par gary tous les couples
tous les projets qui ont été levés
rapidement etienne ressort avec dam des
quatre dans 20 des cas très intéressant
at at la tour 1 il faut trouver une
défense et sa part hier simple 1 il faut
mettre en cavalier sur la case d3 sept
voiles rien d'être le seul à l'essai 3
et le secoue et maintenant etienne
aurait pu pour le long week-end les
beckham qui avait l'air d'être un peu
intéressants ils préfèrent chercher tous
les échanges cavalli procès trois foot
français 3 et profils issus le fameux
double plonge en diagonale justement
foulée 4
le terme technique un foot de canal la
dame était prenable ici parce que le fou
évidemment à en devises et le roi donc
qu'on peut pas prendre à damas cause de
l'échec
et si on prend le fou c'est la torah qui
est prise avec échec tout à fait donc
c'est le double clouage le fou ne peut
pas bouger tour cédant les forces et
hélas etienne échange des pièces faut
penser trois tours pensée 3 donc tout ça
c'est très logique
etienne a réussi à échanger quelques
pièces maintenant son souci c'est la
structure de pions oui parce qu'il ya
des plantes doublé qui sont devenus 2d
le le cinquième coup ces femmes puis en
double qui pour l'instant sont sur les
15 17
le pion 17 notamment le pilote 17 et
arriérée aussi l'option 17 et arrière et
en fait on peut dire que tiennent n'a
pas du tout résolu ses problèmes
d'ouverture puisque dans cette position
simplement sa structure est restée telle
quelle ces pièces active ont été
échangés donc pour l'instant les tiennes
garde toujours les mêmes problèmes et
évidemment contre un technicien que
milliards expérience c'est très délicat
grand roque c5 et l'insecte c'est là
qu'on arrive au cou la première
condition que les premières positions
clés qu'on peut analyser aujourd'hui on
est tout à fait parce qu'après ce coup
c5 qui est intéressant pour quelqu'un
sport line l'idée peut-être on peut dire
l'idée de garry kasparov
ces deux
c'est de bloquer le plan 17 avec ce coup
c'est 5
bon alors l'idée de garry kasparov s'est
bien entendu de poker qui ont 17 il ya
une autre idée c'est d'échanger ses fous
et la dernière et troisième idée que je
vois dans cette position c'est que c'est
d'empêcher les noirs de jouer eux mêmes
c'est cette c5 et c6 le sac ça sedan -
c6 c5 queen tout à fait donc pour
l'instant ce n'était pas possible
lorsqu'il y avait des dames f3 en a huit
échec et mat
wen donc les noirs ne menaçait pas de
jeu le c6 c5 mais bon on avait un
problème de coût dans cette position
dates les blancs ont envie de jouer
dames en 2 3
le but des blancs dans cette position
c'est d'échanger la dame noire
centralisée qui est sur la carte des
quatre qui la pièce la plus active des
malins tout à fait donc ici si les bleus
arrivent et changer cette dame ils vont
se retrouver mieux mais si le fond tout
de suite les noirs auraient pu jouer c6
c5 eux-mêmes et après avoir mis le fourn
bessette
il aurait eu une belle diagonale pour
leur fou belle diagonale avec les casots
4 ça aurait été une bonne position dure
résolu leurs problèmes de nos
d'ouverture tout à fait et ici donc si
on revient un coup avant c'est à dire
avant que les noirs et rock
il ne pouvait pas non plus jouer c6 c5
puisque la torah bit était en prison
donc ici tout l'enjeu de cette position
c'est le coup c6 c5 est ce que les noirs
vont réussir à jouer ou pas puisque les
les voilà et pour les blancs le plan
c'est d'échanger les dames
donc voilà ça fait il ya deux facteurs
dans cette position après grand roque
les blancs jouent eux-mêmes c4 c5 idée
on échange les dames on a une meilleure
structure et en jouent très technique en
finale à la gary kasparov
alors là ils tiennent c'est probablement
une première une précision qui étaient
cités notamment d'ailleurs sur le site
même de garry kasparov kasparov cup
kasparov
qu'est-ce que kasparov points comme une
caisse porsche est encore monté sport
check point com qui est le coup suivant
de etienne bacrot qui est probablement
la première erreur de la partie est
vraiment importante foule bessette
c'est une grave erreur puisque
maintenant garry kasparov bah disons que
maintenant les noirs peuvent plus jouer
c6 c5 comme on l'avait dit de toute
façon c'est sûr puisque maintenant on
est blanc contrôler le même la caste et
5 avec un pion donc se fout c'est du
bois morte il a le même rôle qu'un pion
en fait maintenant voilà on peut dire ça
le l'idée de fouler cette c'est défendre
l'option ces six dont il ya quand même
une idée il ne faut pas non plus
dénigrer comme ça a un coût mais l'idée
c'est de jouer 17 des six mais le
problème c'est que après ce coup d'essai
de d66 aura toujours pas de menace et ça
c'est un gros problème dans cette
position revenons un coup avant au
moment critique aux moments clés de
cette partie après c4 c5 de garry
kasparov
il fallait jouer foot.fr sas est une
c'est une certitude avec poils m'en vais
quand même là les positions un peu
inférieur pour le noir a de toute façon
une position bien entendu inférieurs
pour les noirs mais après faut point f1
donc je ne sais pas si on peut regarder
quelques coups il faut non alors oui
mais tous pointent enfin voilà est dans
cette position il aurait fait le jouet
prenant un coup comme roy bessette ou
quelque chose comme ça en espérant donc
en défendant pioncer 6 en essayant de
jouer 17 des fils après avec
probablement une position peut-être tôt
nabeul alors pourquoi parce que les
faiblesses des noirs sont de ce côté-là
de l'échiquier voilà c'est ces trois
points les faiblesses noir on est parti
sur un axiome de base qui a l'air assez
sain c'est que les blancs doivent
échanger les dames dans cette position
puisque sinon le roi se retrouve dans le
vent la dame noire en d4 est trop forte
donc une fois qu'il aura mis les changer
d'âme on aura le roi du côté des
faiblesses de pions et ça c'est très
important pour défendre finale de toi
c'est le droit était notre côté danse et
s étaient cités on a envie de passer là
dessus parce qu'on va pas avoir le temps
de toute analyse évidemment mais c'était
la honte la solution de toute façon
c'était d'échangés souffou et de pas
leur cycle m17 où il ne fait plus rien
il n'est plus actif du tout il sera
jamais problement de toute la partie
parce que on n'a pas comment les
commandes mais s'active et se fout il
faudrait qu'il est noir puis jouer c6 c5
ou alors qu'il trouve une autre sortie
mais notre sortie ça passe par ou par
l'inca ses 8 17 il faut jouer des cds si
ça va enfin on voit pas comment ce fou à
trouver de l'air donc
ils auraient mieux fait l'échangé en
tout cas oui tout à fait il aurait fallu
les changer après donc approuvé cette on
va regarder 3 ou encore dames 3 très
logique on échange les dames d'un
programme tout reprend dame maintenant
très logiquement ekenge ou 17 décès ce
qui était son idée et la galerie
impitoyable jo 21e qufu c4 donc la
variante qui ont analysé hier en direct
avec frites avec notre moteur d'analysé
et ici les blancs vont certainement un
net avantage puisque évidemment garry
kasparov cette heure-ci un pion il
permet des six fonctions c5
on met ses débuts un triplé ça serait
des pions trip est totalement inefficace
le fou bessette ne sortirait jamais de
la partie et en plus après e 5 e 6 et
aurait un très gros problème pour pour
arrêter ce options ici soi-même maynard
et table il serait totalement
inarrêtable encore de coûts c'est à dire
qui l'a fait roi 17 garry kasparov joue
h4 ouvrons côté où le fou noir n'est pas
c'est à dire quand le chat n'est pas là
les souris dansent
ouais et menaçant non cash 5 casser la
structure en belgique mais casser la
structure tout à fait l'autre côté donc
ici etienne bacrot est obligé de jouer
loribes le coût des six des 5 et après
fou dès 3h 7 hashtag se retrouvant dans
une position horrible vraiment horrible
avec des faiblesses dans tous les sens
notamment le pion à 7 et l'option g6 les
blancs ayant un point fort qui est
l'option de 5 et donc la technique de
garry kasparov a transformé cette
position d'une manière très élégante et
je pense qu'on verra cette partie
intégralement dans des gones al de
vendredi soir alors on va peut-être
arriver juste à la position que les
finales peut-être pour commenter dernier
coup de garry kasparov la position clé
finale voilà qui est au 38e coup cette
position où la lega sport joue le kung
fu prend 1,5 et on verra demain
dans diagonale spéciale pourquoi qui
secoue est gagnant oui oui tout à fait
fou prend 1,5
on verra on expliquera demain place est
gagnant et on verra surtout comment
guernica sport enfin réussi à
transformer ce micro avantage après fou
bessette micro avantage cet avantage en
finale en position gagnante un gain très
très jolie alors deuxième position clé
du jour c'est la partie entre morrow et
beach et gourévitch alors morose et vite
c'est un cc c'est un joueur dangereux
pour kasparov sait qu'on peut le dire je
crois parce que si l'homme style qui lui
permet de marquer beaucoup de points
dans le tournoi et donc ça il peut il
peut arriver a pour l'instant déjà il
est justement après après la partie
d'hier bidon qu'il avait déjà égalité
avec kasparov avec un point sur un an
donc c'est le joueur peut-être un des
joueurs les plus dangereux pour kasparov
et ils jouent contre l'ancien entraîneur
de kasparov lui-même mais craque
gourévitch d'entre vous rediffusera
l'interview pendant pendant ces flash
spécial sarajevo l'interview il explique
comment s'est passée son travail avec
garry kasparov lui-même
on verra ça plus tard monrose levitch
pour le résumer en deux mots c'est un
joueur atypique il un style très
tactique
il a un style très très alternatif très
étrange et jouent des ouvertures connu
m'enfin extrêmement peu connu qui l'a
très bien l'analyser qui la jugent très
profondément
et ici il joue pour l'une des premières
fois disons une ouverture très classique
aux cadets 6 des 4 c'est dire qu'il
prend le centre cabinet fiscal c3 on va
arriver très vite à la pression critique
qui joue contre eux mirail courez vite
chez un grand spécialiste de ces
défenses pire qui est moderne
j'ai six fours 3 c6 donc un début un peu
rampant un petit peu une sorte
d'hippopotames on va arriver très vite
vers la pression incroyable de cette
partie complètement surprenante et est
complètement dingue qu'avaient les bd
cette cavalière 3 pour l'instant tout
est là très calmes tout se passe
tranquillement d'accès à travers normal
un théâtre un coup que je
enfin qu'on va toujours expliqué que
c'était mauvais la france n'est pas
française ne s'est pas d'armes a
toujours expliqué que ce coût était
mauvais puisqu'il ne fallait pas jouer à
quatre sans avoir joué je crois f4 enfin
je ne suis je ne suis plus sûr de rien
dans cette ouverture ça fait longtemps
que je n'avais pas regardé mais il
semble que la carte ça m'a pas l'air
naturel du tout dans cette position en
tout cas c'est le choix de bronze et
beach où j'ai cette fois de donc
formation théologique et ans on ne le
répétera jamais assez les cavaliers ici
on sort les fours et ensuite on rock
tout ça c'est vraiment du domaine de des
enfants de 5 ans en ayant soviétique
voilà petit requis petit orgue cavaillé
des 2 pd2 il rajkovic ou bessette b6 et
là c'est l'heure de la tacc una
surprenant le morose évite tout de suite
ça ils se lancent à l'attaqué avec g4
g2g caf alors c'est très bizarre cette
attaque pourquoi et bien parce que
justement la dame reste en d1 et ne peut
pas bouger ne peut pas s'en aller ne
peut pas aller sur ces drames peuvent
pas faire le grand roque et voilà donc
le grand qui n'est pas à prévoir
et pourtant morose et beach ce donc cela
d'autant plus comment dénicher jouer à 4
un coût qui affaiblirait son rang oui
mais donc il y en aura une pression
qu'il a une tension de lisser son rang
au centre en tout cas que inédit bon
mais je risquais rien au centre donc je
lance aux joints seule attaque
voyez donc c'est effectivement il a bien
blindé le centre il a toutes ces pièces
qui contrôle toutes ses classes centrale
maintenant il se lance à l'attaqué alors
son idée principale c'est évidemment
d'attaquer ce qui valide en rêve 6
ce qui veut dire aussi ce qui n'a pas
trop de cases agréable donc il veut
jouer g5 courez vite je ne l'empêchent
pas je fous 17 et l'as hautmont 5 ou g5
tout à fait dans le plan j'essaie d'en
position clé alors là si c'est la pause
et l'on remarqué que le ce cavalier ne
peut pas les bons mais ni sur la case
des cinq qui est un pion qui attaque ni
sur la case g4 ni sur la case h5
puisqu'il ya vous prend 1,5 kg prend
cinq suicides en france 5 avec une
position écrasante
donc il lui reste qu'une seule case
viable a priori finalement c'est la case
8 oui est sûr qu'elle ait lieu 8 qui n'a
pas été joué on a supposé qu'il y aurait
h 4 h 5 suivi d'une attaque très
violente
alors ce qu'on ne comprend pas c'est à
dire que camille 820 va être le coût
raisonnable
nattawut a mené une attaque avec un
endroit au centre une attaque avec un
roi sans tôt c'est vrai mais une attaque
quand même quand on a ouvert la colonne
h
ça donne toujours des motifs intéressant
mais ce qui est incroyable ici c'est que
cavalier 1,8 salaire tout à fait jouable
marie on va se faire attaquer mais bon
vous invite chacun très très bon
défenseur a priori il ne se passe rien
de spécial et pourtant pour éviter dans
cette version joue cavalier champions le
4/11 coudonc glitch donne une pièce pour
un pion voilà alors résumée comme ça ça
a l'air vraiment mauvais maintenant
c'est vrai que pendant le direct pendant
la partie si on suit cette partie en
direct
on se demande ce qu'a vu gourévitch
puisque on attend tous km 8 et joker en
4 surprise on dirait que c'est lui qui
prend l'initiative et en fait pas du
tout puisque appliqué dépend le 4 des 5
kg 3 il n'a strictement rien montré il a
tout simplement perdu une espèce donc la
deuxième position critique de la journée
c'était celle-là après g5 lecavalier
t'attaquer gollnisch ne joue pas car il
ya huit que s'est il passé dans la tête
de veau à bitche et bien on lui
demandera en fin de tournoi pour le
reportage en peut-être on peut regarder
juste la fin de la partie
rapidement faire défiler peut-être la
position finale on voit que gourévitch à
la fin se retrouve avec carrément une
tour de moins il a continué jusqu'à une
tour de moins en 27e coup oui donc après
tour 20e técou des blancs les blaireaux
carrément une tour de moins et abandonne
abandonner la partie
donc très surprenant de la part de gorée
vite quand même cette perte de fait ce
dans deux pièces au del au deuxième coup
comme ça un coucou rawicz est un joueur
très stable très solide normalement une
perte a comme ça donc c'est difficile à
expliquer en tout cas morose est vite
fait une bonne partie puisqu'il exécute
proprement gourévitch puisque dès le 11e
coup il est complètement gagnon on peut
supposer qu'il était encore préparé dans
l'opposition c'est dire que ce qu'il
avait dit lui qu'il aurait continué pour
le mans a joué des coups très rapidement
donc en tout cas belle prestation de me
raser beach belle très belle prestation
de kasparov et je pense qu'on va passer
notre deuxième rubrique qui est donc le
classement les résultats et les
appareils non on est tout à fait
deuxième rubrique si on peut l'envoyer
que les classements les résultats et les
appariements est-ce qu'on peut envoyer
la deuxième rubrique
allez c'est la magie du direct ont bien
ri voilà donc on va on va revenir alors
sur voilà donc c'est envoyer c'est notre
deuxième voyage qui commence alors
résultats de la première ronde
en bref stéphane donc résultats de la
première ronde en bref donc gorguet faut
investir 1 0 ou encore des failles a
fini par gagner contre mon vestiaire
dans une finale de fou les fous contre
phuc entre deux fous père de foot pardon
contrefout et cavaliers donc ce qui fait
moi ça m'a impressionné quand même parce
qu'il n'y avait pas de plus en avance
c'était l'égalité 2 pions y avait des
pions sur les deux ailes quelques jours
avantageux pour les fous une très très
belle réalisation technique de thierry
gaiffe donc dans cette première ronde
qui regorge ce n'est pas non plus un
habitué des grands tournois mais ici le
prend bien le une première initiative et
commence bien son tournoi donc kasparov
raccroc donc on connaît un résultat 1-0
en veine commenté la partie
bronzé vie du bourg évite même même
punition 1-0 shirov adams et donc on en
a parlé tout à l'heure sur fadam
finalement partie nulle mais koshiro
fait gagner en plus on a gagné un point
à l'ouverture il a réussi à gagner un
pion de plus mais ça n'a pas suffi
michael adams était un défenseur hors
pair mais a réussi à obtenir la position
est arrivé à la partie nulle oui donc on
voit leur envol placement en valeur
grâce au classement pendant qu'il est là
quand même dans le premier cas ce parent
en tenons aux hélices topalov égorgé
voilà on arrivait à la partie de topalov
qui a gagné contre short avec les noirs
donc 5 3 premiers ex-aequo
ils sont quatre ex-aequo à la première
place voilà et son 4e à la 2e place ce
colloque mariachis refait à damas la
cinquième du couple à 100 et puisque ce
colosse baril affiche ehrhoff et adams
et donc qu'ils ont cédé deux parties
nulles en fait les deux parties nulles
et en fait les perdants des partis et
des premiers
enfin des premiers cités finalement que
l'on trouve à la fin cros gourévitch or
tu es mauvais escient donc voilà qui ont
perdu tous leurs leur leur parti donc
voilà donc ces années ça démarre sur les
chapeaux de roue ça fait trois groupes
de quatre personnes simplement donc il
ya eu deux parties nulles les quatre
parties décisives
on peut pas pour un tournant peut
paraître un départ un départ plus
explosif parce que
on peut le départ le plus catastrophique
pour un tournoi c'est quand on parle de
suspense c'est que des parties nulles
donc là tout le monde est dans le même
lot dès le début ça rien n'est en rien
ne se passe mais là il ya un groupe qui
a gagné de quatre joueurs un groupe de
quatre joueurs dans qui ont perdu un
groupe de quatre joueurs qu'on fait nul
donc on se retrouve avec un schéma idéal
pour toutes les combinaisons possibles
oui mais ça c'est vrai tout à fait donc
oui non ces explosifs et 4 résultat
positif c'était à quatre gains acquis at
résultats décisifs dans la première
ronde sur six c'est un très beau
pourcentage qui rendrait nos amis
espagnols complètement fou où notre ami
louis sur un terreau qui est fan de 200
doit se retourner
depuis chez lui puisqu'il n'a alors
d'avoir des résultats aussi explosive
quand on se retrouve à lille nice on va
c'est vraiment très chaud ici c'est
vraiment très chaud on va commenter donc
tout de suite les appariements pour la
deuxième ronde qui a lieu aujourd'hui
qu'on commencera donc demain
deuxième rendre donc adams contre
kasparov donc ça ça va être chaud ça ça
va être très très chaud etienne bacrot
joue contre gorgui f donc
finalement c'est peut-être pas un
mauvais tirage ce qu'ils n'avaient pas
j'ai déjà joué contre lui au championnat
du monde
je ne sais pas on se renseignera pour
demain par contre etienne a une carte à
jouer contre qui regorgent des filets
les blancs il faut pas non plus qu'il
force trop c'est à dire qu'il faut que
si nul nul ça devrait lui suffire et
devrait satisfaire avec la nul mais il
peut quand même essayer de la gagner il
peut la jouer balayer fonds spécial
gourévitch shirov sokolov choc et
topalov morose et vie tu vois là et on
vous donne rendez vous donc demain pour
la suite de ce spécial sarajevo
oh
m
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce diagonale
spécial sarajevo avec avec moi pour
présenter cette émission bertrand guyard
bonjour bertrand bonjour et le voit donc
émission spéciale sarajevo avec toujours
une émission décomposée en deux parties
la première partie étant les positions
clés et la seconde étant classement
résultat a pareillement tout et divers
donc là on vous retrouve après ce week
end assez long puisque nous avons raté
trois parties la partie de vendredi de
samedi et de dimanche donc il ya
beaucoup de commentaires
beaucoup de choses à dire nous on a eu
la chance d'être là vendredi pour on
peut vous le dire tout de suite la
première victoire de bakou dans le
tournoi et puis bah vous allez voir
qu'il s'est passé beaucoup de choses sur
wickens un week end c'est un tournoi
dynamique difficile et doivent enfin je
crois que tout le monde attend que tu
nous présentes dont il partit donc des
parties très très chaude effectivement
alors on va tout de suite commencer donc
par notre première rubrique puisqu'il ya
vraiment beaucoup de choses à dire il ya
des il ya des monuments qui ont été
faits donc la première partie de cette
émission les positions clés des
positions clés donc
donc voilà les positions paix alors
c'est donc parti pour cette première
analyse donc là si on peut regarder la
première position qu'on va vous proposer
la voilà donc c'est aujourd'hui c'est en
vert et jaune
nous avons changé les couleurs diagonale
pour une émission exceptionnelle mans
c'est la partie donc détiennent battront
contre le
l'arménien move spéciale oui il faut
revenir sur le début du tournoi on le
redit encore une fois c'est etienne
bacrot c'est son premier grand super
taureau international sexe laisse une
autre dimension si on était en boxe
c'est les poids lourds et chez les poids
lourds et c'est dur est le premier dans
la première ronde la première partie on
est mort on chez les joueurs d'échecs la
première partie prend le le plus lourd
des poids lourds il prend il prend
kasparov avec avec les pièces noires et
hyper un hyper parce que c'est dur et là
bon on était très content parce qu'on a
vu je crois tout les deux tous les deux
c'est cette partie en direct c'est une
espagnole donc un grandes variantes ou
etienne a bien joué début move session
est un joueur jeune c'est un mois que je
connais un tout petit peu pour l'avoir
vu dans un tournant en france ferait
sympathique élan etienne dominent la
partie et il faut qu'il fasse quelque
chose alors eloi qu'est-ce qui fait oui
alors effectivement mauricien et 9 ccja
les jeunes jouent d ouverture assez
original est ici etienne a réussi à
prendre le meilleur dans l'ouverture
c'est à dire qu'avec les noirs
il a réussi à obtenir une très bonne
position donc voilà tout de suite la
première position position clé de cette
troisième ronde du tournoi de sarajevo
etienne bacrot avec les noirs contre
stars gagnent obsession avec les blancs
et c'est à étienne de jouer donc ici
etienne et prolongation on voit qu'il a
deux pions passé devions passer qui sont
sur les cases c4 et des trois qui sont
extrêmement bien passé extrêmement
avancé une tour sur la seconde rangée un
fou contre un cavalier bref tout est là
pour
sur une très belle victoire mais étienne
là se fait un petit peu peur
toi tu dis un petit peu peur l'on va on
va comprendre ce que tu veux dire on va
comprendre ce que je veux dire c'est à
dire que ici etienne joue le coup donc
fou procurons vous proposions f 3 ar
quelle est l'idée l'idée de ce coup
c'est un sacrifice évidemment de
destruction sacrifices qu'on qualifie de
destruction puisque ça va détruire le r
les pions qui sont devant le roi blanc
ça va détruire ce rempart d'options et
ça va donc mettre le roi blanc dans une
situation assez précaire c'est assez
difficile assez délicate et en cumulant
cette attaque sur le roi avec eux qui
ont passé s etienne espère remporter la
partie assez facilement voyons qu ici
ici ici il faut prendre le foot ici avec
taiwan ya pas que ce soit il faut
prendre le fou dame prend menace matt
maintenance des jets d'eau matin que
keane et parable que par une seule
manoeuvre si je ne me suis pas trompé
c'est de faire un échec intermédiaire
puisque a pas de défense directes contre
sonate donc dames c'est cet échec le roi
vient enrichissent et maintenant c'est
l'idée c'était de rapatrier la dame
d'objets 3 donc là il faut pas se
tromper quand même
alors là pour l'instant et y'en a dû
voir ça va on le suppose
il a dû calculer problème en plus loin
parce qu'il suffit pas de se dire non
plus j'ai d'options passé savait gagner
il faut calculer assez précisément alors
c'est là qu'on va voir que la fin est
vraiment superbe puisque apparemment il
avait tout calculé jusqu'au bout en
partant du début de la combinaison fu
panda frères dang tran dames les blancs
sont obligés de jouer cavalier grand dam
et maintenant tour le 5 mars avec l'idée
de secouer ses deux donc un de couper le
cavalier là on voit qu'une tour placé en
diagonale à une casse du cavalier donc
une classe d'écart ça contrôle beaucoup
de casse du cavalier et la deuxième idée
c'est de continuer à garder le contrôle
de cette colonne pour couper le roi
blanc encore entré chez le roi blanc de
revenir au jeu
et puis une petite pointe un qu'il faut
tuer parce qu'elle va planer où il reste
dans cette position les blancs peuvent
toujours essayer de pousser leurs pions
b le pion qui est là pour libérer leur
le pion à créer un autre pion passée
donc il faut toujours faire attention
quand même
cette finale il faut faire attention aux
blancs qui ont d'options contre 1 c'est
à dire qu'ils peuvent toujours sacrifié
pour faire passer le 2e et ça
effectivement là l'idée c'est que la
tour contrôle très bien cette case 7/5
manger donc etienne ce premier également
contre ça d'un coup totalement
multifonctions tours 5
un coup de centralisation oui c'est
blanc font par agnès moins qu de amenant
leur droit vers le centre et la sel
heures d'avancé les pions bain avec ses
4 c3 et la mauve cession va trouver
vraiment la bonne défense là elle
prônant la seule défense il va jouer
cavalier f1 alors ça c'est le bon coup
le bon coup parce que justement ça
permet aux cavaliers de revenir sur
l'a43 sa contrôle aussi la casse des
deux essayera ça commence à neutraliser
les pions alors ici on était tous un peu
inquiet en suivant cette partie en
direct puisque on s'est dit on mais
finalement etienne qu'est ce qu'il a vu
ouais
oui je crois que même ce qui est c'est
assez rigolo internet parce qu'il y
avait ce vide l'air qui est passée par
là william la grand-messe vie de l'air
est un joueur à plus de 2700 points elo
et qui était pas sûr non plus
visiblement dans ses commentaires
un personne n'était sûr il y avait deux
grands maîtres très fort qui était en
train de en train de discuter sur
l'évaluation de cette position personne
ne savait si les noirs si etienne donc
été gagnant si etienne à les firmes ou
si peut-être même qu'ils pouvaient être
moins bien moi c'est difficile c'est
difficile mais en tout cas les les
commentaires partiez dans tous les sens
et là on a fait un doute on s'est dit
comment est ce que etienne a pu rater
une partie aussi facile
un parti qui semblait facile et là c'est
que ça continue toujours très précis
tour deux échecs roef troyes et tours b2
dire que maintenant que lecavalier a
quitté son poste de g3 il n'y a plus
aucun problème pour le laisser c'est à
dire qu'il faut l'empêcher
enfin il n'y a plus aucune idée de
l'ancienne avocate puisqu'il ne peut
plus y aller donc la tour b 2 3 3 donc
là on se dit ça y est etienne par les
pions et là il y avait vu alors ici hein
on va voir la fin il faut avoir tout vu
quand même enfin c'est clair que les
blancs là vont prendre le document ça
paraît très probable que les deux pions
passé noir les leur forme actuelle leurs
seules forces ça va passer à la
casserole ça va sauter complètement donc
ici il ya un problème pour pointe
bretonne et il a trouvé le bon truc donc
il joue le c2 1 menace de mettre la
tourbe et de en b1 donc là tout est
forcée et c'est là c'est ça qui est
boudé dans l'idée c'est de promouvoir
l'un des deux pions et là dans quelque
peu la petite pointe que tu viens de
montrer sert le petit coup tactique
tout est là petit coup tactique est
important un le petit coup tactique
importance et oblige d'ailleurs les
blancs à jouer le seul coup on contrôle
cette case le cavalier en d2 et là ça a
l'air pas mal parce qu'on a tout bloqué
et là on se dit voilà tour ben c'est pas
possible parce qu'il a tout reprend tour
puis on prend cavaliers pros on est tous
les pions sont bloqués au prochain
foulée blanche droits à pension les
blancs vont prendre l'option la mission
des trois jeux pas si vous voyez quel
côté du roi donc ici tout semble tout
semble perdu 1
mais là c'est là qu'il ya justement là
points 0,16 euro qui est arrivé assez
d'être actif à trois c'est à dire qu'il
y avait un troisième pion passé donc
c'était il y en avait pas d'eau à
stopper mais y en avait trois et celui
là fait toute la différence puisque
maintenant donc move session juin coûts
intermédiaires qui ne change rien à la
pointe et to b 5 tours prend b5 et là il
prend le tueur détroit voilà donc là a
priori tous les pions blancs sont en
prise là on voit l'option l'option à 3
est en prise le pion ces 2 également
donc on se dit c'est cuit vapeur
déception est donc super beaucoup
touraille ou alors il faut essayer à 3.2
les faux culs les montres il faut
expliquer les trois pointes donc
première possibilité pour les blancs bon
déjà première remarque c'est que les
noirs menacé un dame mais c'était ça
c'est ça c'est une remarque importante
il menace également tour prend tôt voilà
donc pour ça il ya trois possibilités
pour les blancs première ses cavaliers
pro tour la deuxième s'est toujours
entouré la troisième ses cavaliers b3
ces trois possibilités
on va commencer par kébé 3 qui est la
plus simple éliminé puisque après qu'ils
aient b3 il ya non pas tout reprend
cavaliers échec
enfin qui marchera aussi d'ailleurs mais
il ya aussi tout reprend tour ce
cavalier prendre
jean plus d'âme c'est fini tout
simplement qu'il ya des trois n'est pas
une défense alors sur cavaliers pro tour
on voit que justement les blancs ne
contrôle plus la caisse de promotion on
a fait une intersaison fils
d'interception de déviation donc et pour
tout on pousse dame
voilà et c'est terminé mais c'était à
une dame c'est ça va gagner puisque les
pièces blanches sont mal mal organisés
dans cette position donc nouvelles
possibilités et la plus l'appeler jolie
donc qui n'a pas été joué puisque là les
joueurs ont compris ce qui se passait
c'est de jouer tout reprend tourner
c'est à dire que max essien abandonné
après c'est quoi la mode session a
abandonné il y avait également donc tout
repentant way
puis on prend toujours forcé promotion
dam d'ailleurs d'un cavalier programme
est là le troisième le troisième pion le
petit dernier joue à 3 à 2 de peu le
dernier mais pas le moindre mais pas le
moindre puisque c'est celui qui pas qui
va passer en fait nous appelons donc
après à 3,2 de menaces tu comprends
cavaliers option pouces dames et on ne
peut pas parler de menace donc c'est
terminé c'était encore super ça nous a
fait plaisir en la vie en direct de
cette partie parce que parce que c'est
dur
elle et puis vous allez comprendre on va
comprendre tout de suite que c'est
réduire ce tournoi puisque on va parler
alors on montre d'abord une autre partie
extraordinaire oui alors on veut l'avoir
rapidement puisque le temps presse mais
il ya eu une partie une partie
totalement phénoménal édifiante je
dirais même c'est c'est la surprise du
tournoi c'est alexei shirov alors alexei
shirov qui joue ici contre topalov ont
fait 2 2 fait les de l'attak ces deux
joueurs qui jouent à fond pour le gain
alexei shirov al'avantage d'être en plus
extrêmement technique un joueur très
fort techniquement et ici alors là la
partie partie justement dans tous les
sens c'est totalement phénoménal ce qui
s'est passé donc on va passer rapidement
sur l'ouverture puisque l'ouverture
c'est pas notre notre sujet dans cette
émission diagonale spécial sarajevo
tout ce qu'on peut dire c'est que c'est
une défense française walid
on va vous défilez tranquillement la
partie c'est la variante à la note dans
ce tournoi de sarajevo donc ça c'est
quand même une chose qui est qu'il faut
signaler donc tous asseyez hughes arrive
donc là kasparov dans cette position
avait joué j'ai trois ce qui est une
possibilité contre gourevitch shirov les
plus violents je vous sais de ces quatre
donc prenons le centre tout de suite
être simple il faut
repliez lecavalier fouet 6 topalov
commence sa stratégie sur case noire
puisque elle excelle science n'a plus de
foot cases noires voilà ils minent le
centre des 58 passes et donc ne nous
attardons pas trop sur ses positions la
grand roque aux cinq les noirs prennent
l'eau sans doit jouer aux cartes
apparemment la position a l'air assez
prometteuse pour les noirs finale h4 b5
donc là ça commence ça commence à une
position solide on veut malheureusement
on n'a pas le temps de tout commenter
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que là on a
vraiment de joueurs soumah peut faire un
commentaire général de joueurs qui ont
envie de tuer l'autre quoi c'est un peu
violent mon commentaire mais c'est donc
là tu sais je me souviens qu'on a vu le
parti aussi en direct et on a dit ça
peut ça ça peut pas faire du loup c'est
difficile de firmi paraguay c'est vrai
nos moeurs ce qui risque il faut voir
dans ces parties hypertendus puisque là
c'est vraiment car les noirs on la perd
de fou les noirs ont quatre pions
avancées déjà au centre s'est gardé un
déséquilibre qui est tellement total que
effectivement c'est impossible d'arriver
à compenser tous ces déséquilibres donc
pas d'égalité dans cette position par
contre on ne sait pas qui est nul ça
c'est une certitude voilà donc la clé
sur le joug des cinq des six il avait un
pion qui étaient bien tenus en d5 il
avançant des six ils se font ce qu'elles
veulent et c'est ce qui est marrant
c'est qu'on n'essaye même pas de
question
c'est très dur à expliquer tous ses
coups 17
donc là
sa force un peu ce qu'on fout 17 alors
ici il ya toujours cette fameuse dualité
du pion très avancé c est ce qu il est
fort ou est-ce qu'il est faible
qui c'est difficile à dire on ne veut
pas répondre m une idée pour les noirs
ça peut être d'amener le calice et six
sont des 4 d'ailleurs ces programmes et
qui permettrait le gain de ce pion 17
donc on ne peut pas permettre ça il faut
devancer la devancer la menace il faut
devancer qui est des cartes avec dame
d624 donc ça continue à partir cavaliers
des 5 contre attaque contre attaque sur
le sur le x 6 le fou s'en va arranger 7
est maintenant kg 5 donc là les trois
derniers coups cheer up c'est quand même
sympa il a mené sa dame en plein milieu
du camp ennemi il a mené les deux
cavaliers met en avant mais ici on se
demande toujours
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'est ce qu'y fait
la personne shirov peut tenir parce que
il a enfin rapidement les noirs ont
quand même un superbe francs g7 qui peut
attaquer le roi blanc
et puis ils ont le centre donc c'est
vraiment une position déséquilibre est
donc là on n'a malheureusement pas le
temps de montrer beaucoup de variantes
et puis on va regarder surtout la
combinaison qui est magnifique
j'ai absolument fantastique et puis
regardez bien regardez bien cher cher
télénautes le fouet fin qui ne jouent
pas qui n'est pas développé est fausse
et c'est lui là c'est lui la star de la
cause et si vous allez voir le fouet fin
de cahier des cas donc là on empêche
effectivement je veux fin de sortie
maintenant puisque sur faut de zurich
épreuve deux échecs ça c'est
inadmissible surtout des trois options
kung fu cavaliers ou cet échec ça
commence comme ça donc là c'est
s'efforcer ont un jeu suit donc l'on
peut imaginer des combinaisons à base de
dames propension à vii si c'était
possible
malheureusement ça n'est pas possible il
faut regarder si c'est vrai qu'avec
shirov à l' on ne peut pas donné de
variantes mais il faut tout imaginer ce
que c'est un garçon qui calculent qu'ils
calculent qu'ils calculent un angle à
bachirov s'il ya quelque chose à trouver
il va le trouver et s'il ya quelque
chose à voir il va le voir
c'est sûr qu'à venir cet échec donc là
là alors ça j'étais très surpris dans
cette fissure d'entourage 3 on sort
encore une tour
ouais comme les débutants assez souvent
un coût
mais elle 5 à 4 donc là l'option f4
n'est évidemment pas en prise puisque
tout le monde a les pièces ans priscilla
dame venait prendre ses pions la dame
noire pourrait le cavalier blanc tout
simplement 3 mai donc là on se demande
on se dit voilà moi quand j'ai vu cette
position quand j'ai vu que je rentre je
crois bien je me suis dit ça y est il
est cuit tout simplement parce que les
blancs ne peuvent plus amélioré une
seule pièce toutes les pièces blanches
sont au maximum
il ya plus d'améliorations de possibles
alors après j'ai commencé à réfléchir
côté noir je me suis dit exactement là
je me
qu'est-ce que vous avez des noirs le vfb
lübeck bouger donc là j'arrivais à cette
conclusion étonnante dans cette partie
donc shirov topalov de joueur magique
plus personne ne peut avancer que
personne ne peut rien faire alors il a
trouvé un plan quand même veine topalov
djoumbé des cinglés 4 l'idée étant à 6 à
celui de tours à huit ans à 6 pour
déloger cette dame blanche donc d'un
procès 5 n'est pas n'est pas
recommandable puisque s'appellerait
pions 17
j'ai donc un des facteurs critiques est
très très important de la pression
blanche mais là le pion il est surtout
ils empêchent les noirs de jouer enfin
les empêche tout revient et tour s'évite
mais on empêche tout il n'empêche dame
rouge puisque ils menacent toujours
d'avancer
donc ils ferment il est très fort ses
pions et la superbe au coude avec ces
chiffres je pense que c'est l'élément
magique incroyable de cette partie alors
là je peux dire quelque chose à nous on
regarde évidemment regarder on faisait
autre chose ont travaillé en même temps
je regarde cette partie et d'un seul
coup et loi me dit mais mais le fou et
emprises la ba oui il est en prison
n'avait pas tellement regardé et puis
bah c'est tout on va voir parce que oui
il va voir alors donc l'investissement
total of n'a pas pris une foule donc là
ce qui nous a fait croire d'abord une
erreur de transcription puisque fou de
bétheny topalov joue le coup f4f trois
ans la no qu'il commence par ça sur quoi
le safety of production g nice a changé
en rien parce que ça ne change rien au
fond de la combi noire à pied superbe
alors qu'à l'est plus maintenant voilà
c'est parce que nous on était en train
de chercher
et puis parce que c'est quand même donné
une pièce net sans échec sens en coûts
directs où il ne veut on peut même pas
menacé de quoi ce soit donc ici on se
demande quelle est l'idée et finalement
on a trouvé d'ailleurs ça a été jouée
par excès shirov l'idée donc cesser on a
dévié le cavalier de la casse des 4
pourquoi parce que maintenant on a
libéré notre dame qui n'était obligé de
défendre l'option 17
donc je donc d'un procès 5 avec une
grosse menace bertrand avec une grosse
menace et elle a maintenant maintenance
et c'est compréhensible si la dame
arrive sur la case qui est pointée par
éloi belle menace matt est pratiquement
ce matin est imparable c'est assez un
math de débutants mais alors celui là il
est vraiment violent et en plus il y
aura la menace aussi pourquoi pas dame
prend pions également avec la z fameux
matt des deux cavaliers alors l'idée
était double comme jelly c'était 2-2
permettre à la tour de défendre deux
pions et en même temps de dévier le
cavalier de la défense dave cinq mois il
passé c'est quand même fou mais faut que
tout ça tienne il faut que tout ça fait
maintenant plusieurs possibilités pour
le noir une possibilité serait de
remettre le cavalier sur cette case des
quatre voilà le cavalier 2e 2 en d4
ça c'est une possibilité sa contrôler la
case f5 ça attaque l'option 17 c on
aurait juste perdu en temps mais là il y
aurait donc tout reprend cavaliers et
après foutront tous non pas d'un profond
échec qui ne sert à rien mais simplement
des 9,5 suivi du matin es7 voilà donc
ici big problème on ne peut pas jouer
que l'idée 4 donc il trouve un coup
assez logique finalement
notre ami topalov c'était le coup tu
regardais pendant l'analyse mais là bon
là on a en revanche maintenant on avait
tout calculé jusqu'au bout et c'est
maintenant facile en était l'idée c'est
ça il faut l'avoir 403 quatre coups
avant de comprendre qu'il faut qu'il
faut donner ce fou un se fout d'eux qui
en même temps que développement ami ami
débutants pensez-y même au 25e coup faut
mettre ces pièces un jeu même coop
veulent quand elles se font pendant un
coup oui donc ce qui était beau c'était
froid bien préparant foudre et la
recette les graisses syrie depuis très
très longtemps
effectivement ici c'est la confirmation
je pense que n'importe quel grand maître
aurait calculé jusqu'au bout ici
peut-être même les joueurs
internationaux
dan f5 menace m'attaque lecavalier
unique défense calais gil 6 h 5
c'est alors qu'on ne prend pas le club
des mauges et y songe ou h5 on va le
prendre avec un pion parce que ça va
justement permettre de mettre cette tour
h3 la tour blanche qui est sur le bord
de l'échiquier enjeu d'un procès depuis
son projet 6 hélas là on n'est pas loin
de la fin est d'ailleurs cet abandon
c'est à vendre de lésigny topalov dans
cette pétition
ben non mais c'était formidable c'est
formidable et faut reconnaître que
shirov c'est un joueur formidable c'est
un joueur qui est qui il avait bien joué
c'est là dans notre tournoi donc on est
très content mais il est pour l'instant
c'est le seul qui tient tête à kasparov
dans ce tournoi c'est un joueur qui est
sympathique qui est dédié au jeu et
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire d'autre sur lui c'est qu'il n'a pas
de chance et qu'il avait le droit de
rencontrer kasparov il n'a pas m'en vais
reparler de ça on va on va continuer oui
tout à fait donc alexei shirov en
superbe forme qui gagnent ici une très
très belle partie contre 28 aux pas
l'offre donc les deux plus belles
positions qu'on a trouvé ce week end
sont ces deux parties la petite
combinaison détiennent bacrot avec cette
promotion à ce sujet assez joli et cette
superbe partie de la xl shirov contre
vesnina pas l'offre donc fin de la
première de la première partie on va
tout de suite lancé la deuxième rubrique
de l'émission qui est donc résultats
classements a pareillement qu est ce que
vous les serres
alors donc trois parties nous ont
échappé ce week end pour cause de
justement de week end donc nous revenons
ce lundi avec trois parties a commenté
3e larron 3,44 et la route sainte les
joueurs n'ont pas chômé avec une au
round 3 explosive marotte explosif
puisque il ya eu cinq gains et une seule
nul
ouais donc on ne peut pas rêver d'un
score plus plus éloquent c'est vraiment
très combatif là bas alors on y va dans
l'ordre morose et beach bas sokolov
ailleurs j'ai vu c'est rapidement cette
partie c'était un gambit du roi il à la
matraque et super grand vide une belle
boucherie short bahreïn 01 donc là la
partie ce pas la meilleure partie tshirt
de sa vie nouvelle de ce fonds pourra
dire effectivement une affaire est un
pion de manière assez légères shirov
topaloff
on l'a vue superbe super d'un zéro
caspar gourevitch alors là coup de tête
basse qu'on peut dire sur kasparov
on va pas être trop casse parvient pas
ce que parce qu'il n'y en a pas il a pu
besoin de supporteurs d'arrimer c'est un
joueur qui c'est un joueur qui est
toujours difficile à jouer
c'est à dire que quand il est quand il
est foutu ce qui l'a été dans cette
partie certainement un moment donné ou
pas très bien mais les y pose des
problèmes et gourévitch ils avaient au
bout du fusil a été incapable de le non
seulement de le finir de faire nul mais
en même temps il sait il s'est fait
battre
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut dire il est
la galerie c'est à dire que il est la
même quand ils jouent mal ils gagnent
donc
il est quand même en tête du tournoi
avec shirov enfin là quand même dans
cette partie il était vraiment
complètement clairement on peut le dire
il allait se faire mater il était très
mal contre gourévitch en plus ce qui est
quand même pas le punch fois dans ce
tournoi il fait office de entre
guillemets de joueurs faibles mais bon
c'est quand même un super joueur et
kasparov était vraiment errements oui
bon alors que comment est ce que tu veux
que j'ai d'abord c'est un ancien
entraîneur de caspar donc être toujours
une part de c'est difficile de jouer
contre quelqu'un qu'on connaît bien
qu'est ce que je voulais il était paris
s'est dit il a quand même joué kasparov
on l'a vu l'appartement dix avec c'est
quand même lui qui met le feu
en sacrifiant une qualité les peaux
obliger un homme mais bon l'idée y met
le feu et font et finalement il joue
avec beaucoup de courage
il est champion du monde il pourrait
jouer différemment
il ne joue pas c'est un super c'est un
superbe champion que voilà ce que je
pense
d'accord donc disons que kasparov a bien
à bien gérer cette partie a bien joué il
a sacrifié il a été chaud il a pris des
risques et ça a fini par payer
mais il est quand même passé par une
position perdante mais elle s'est donc
kasparov toujours toujours la gueule un
nouveau point marqué gorgui f adams nul
ne peut pas grand chose à dire sauf que
ces deux joueurs là vous allez voir un
classement sont solides ce sont deux
joueurs solides ils sont elles pas très
rigolo mais c'est des bons lift alors
voilà c'est d'aider des baux lifteurs on
est tout à fait mauvais escient bacrot 0
1 ça nous a fait plaisir parce que ces
vagues etienne
forcément va s'offrir dans ce tournoi
parce que c'est plus petit classement
parce que c'est son premier tournoi
parce qu'il est le plus jeune mais pour
l'instant il se défend pas trop mal mais
on va parler d'eux on va parler de lui
on va reparler lui compte quatre dont
qui a eu lieu samedi sokolov shirov nul
partie assez tranquille short pas
évident ce nul également donc là c'est
en fait c'était le repos des guerriers
puisqu'il ya eu énormément nul dans
cette partie topalov kasparov parties
nulles alors ça c'était une nulle
théorie n'est qu'une impression
topalov h une vente forcée dans un une
sorte de candidat mais rend slave
quelque chose sur case blanche une
ouverture sur caisse blanche bon nul
n'est elle pas répéter son cours 25e
coup gourevitch d'orgue et appelant là
où quoi d'autre comme résultat nul nul
forcé ces deux joueurs fond de court
bah c'est à dire deux joueurs franco et
puis bon c'est ce que tu viens expliqué
c'est difficile il ya une part il ya une
part de créativité à ce niveau là donc
on peut pas je sais qu' à l'heure et à
luiz rennes terreau quel grand
organisateur du tour na li dares qui
donne des amendes aux joueurs quand ils
font nul
d'abord une partie nulle c'est pas
forcément une partie in intéressante
c'est pas une forcément une part et de
la partie où il n'y a pas eu de combats
et puis c'est difficile de tous les
jours de donner le meilleur de soi même
d'être créative de vouloir se battre
certainement ce qui lui arrivait oui oui
et oui sont fait peur la veille 1 ils
sont fait très peur
c'est vrai adams mauvais escient nul ça
c'était une sicilienne time and off avec
g3 assez longue c'est assez ennuyeuse et
notre petit français etienne bacrot donc
après sa victoire contre le fc sion il
était revenu à un point et demi sur 3
s'incline contre bas relief avec les
noirs alors j'ai pas vu l'habitude à
regarder la rapidement la partie
j'ai regardé rapidement la partie
c'était assez difficile pour etienne
alors chez gm oui un trou 20 trouve bon
non mais ce congrès ce qu'on peut dire
on va faire un commentaire général on
reviendra sur ses parties ce qui est dur
c'est que pour la première fois c'est
etienne jouait un catégorie je crois 19
20 ou 18 c'est à dire la moyenne et lot
de tous les adversaires à 2007 c'est à
dire que ce sont tous des grands
champions 1 le plus faible du tournoi
après lui c'est ce call of qui est déjà
un joueur très très dur sinon vous avez
des joueurs comme gueorguiev qui sont
peut-être pas forcément connus du grand
public
vous avez des joueurs comme shore qui
sont quand même qu'un superbe attaquant
et puis vous avez les meilleurs joueurs
du mans
ça fait évidemment kasparov vous avez
évidemment shirov vous avez évidemment
topaloff
et puis bas relief qui est un joueur qui
joue entre 2680 et de 1710 depuis
maintenant pratiquement dix ans oui tout
à fait mais d'ailleurs barrier font que
c'est un excellent joueur positionnelle
et là il a fait subir sa loi etienne je
mens réelle maintenant de la partie
c'était une anglaise longuet est
horrible où toutes les pièces se
replacer etienne n'a pas subi n'a pas
tenu en fait cette tension terrible 35
kasparov sokolov
alors là j'ai une j'ai une photo de g 0
1 alors qu'il s'agit évidemment de 1,0
kasparov a battu sokolov shirov a battu
short belle partie également donc là
seuil et les joueurs se sont un peu
réveillé morozevich bas relief nul
d'orgueil topalov nul les joueurs
bulgares n'ont pas combattu trop
longtemps mauvaise escient gourévitch
gourévitch retour un point pour
gourévitch évaluer l'état zéro je crois
au début il était à 0 il a fait nul et
ensuite il a gagné donc retour de gros
reach entre guillemets puisque hors dû
battre kasparov il n'a pas inaperçu et
bacrot adams 0 1
là encore la dame s'est pas c'est pas
moi c'est pas ma tasse de thé
sincèrement mais c'est un certain c'est
cette ville as des grandes années quoi
ces deux villes a sauté lycée
accueillera mènent ils ramènent il
ramène etienne il a joué bareille il a
joué kasparov
il a joué au fc sion il a joué
bas relief et puis jouer adams et puis
demain il joue quoi ils jouent contre
eux qui trace bien demain on va voir
tweet très rapidement en tout cas adams
vincent n'a pas perdu de partie ils
avaient fait quatre nuls et remporté sa
première victoire donc très vite
maintenant après avoir publié ses cinq
premières rondes
on va voir le classement le classement
du tournoi donc on va envoyer le
déroulement de ce classement
voilà le voilà donc en tête l'ami gary
neville l'ami gary ex-aequo avec alexei
shirov deux joueurs à quatre points mais
c'est clairement les deux plus forts ces
sont les deux plus forts ce sont les
deux hommes en forme et ils se sont pas
rencontrés donc c'est super et scheer
fouras les blancs dans cette rencontre
superbe morozevich bas relief les
suivent à trois points et demi donc on
peut dire que les quatre premiers
joueurs sont russes oui on regarde cédé
4 us du tournoi qu'ils sont en tête
adamsberg f 3 points donc bolt belle
performance de gorgui f qu'on attendait
un peu en demi-teinte ici adams on
l'attendait évidemment topalov le joueur
un joueur ce port de montréal est enfin
là on arrive dans l'est les joueurs qui
ont mal dans ce tournoi puisqu'il ya un
gros écart topaloff avait deux points et
demi et là ils ont tous un point et demi
sokolov bacrot gourévitch et ensuite en
tant que deux ans que deux tournois a
tiré sur nos obsessions et les
chercheurs short à mon avis ça va être
il ya bien des chances pour qu'il
finisse dans les vernis parce qu'il nous
a quand même montré à une qualité de jeu
il peut t'arriver de fatigue alors
pourquoi expliquer ses sautes de avant
de se dire au revoir ses sautes de forme
et faut être créatif aux échecs faut
avoir envie de se battre
il ya quand même une forte tension sur
les parties de quatre heures et vous
voyez bien de temps en temps ils gagnent
tout et puis le lendemain ils sont
obligés de fuir nulle parce qu'on peut
difficilement avoir pendant pendant
toute l'année pendant onze routière
pendant ce parti de haut niveau toujours
la même envie de gagner peut-être
également que short
on n'a plus cette expérience du haut
niveau et que c'est son premier combat
depuis longtemps et qu'il faut se
remettre dans le bain tout simplement
non oui il allait bien sur les dix
doigts fins de tournois prévoir en tout
cas diverses diverses éléments demain
journée de repos après demain non enfin
cet après midi journée de repos donc
demain pas démission après demain on
reprend alors on vous commentera les
parties de la ronde 6 alors a
pareillement rapidement en bref
sokolov contre gorgue f donc ça devrait
être une partie assez tranquille chante
kasparov tout est possible short a battu
kasparov plusieurs fois il le fait
souffrir à chaque fois non réservistes
contre chir offre rencontre phare je
dirais de cette saisie à la même file de
voler ça risque de saigner dans cette
partie mordille shirov topalov move
cession d'opel of va la jouer c'est sûr
gourévitch bacrot alors là espérons qu
etienne tiendra le choc
et pour finir bas relief adams deux très
beaux joueurs très solides donc voilà
donc de toutes façons nous évite shirov
compte rendu complet de cette partie
qu'yvette et qui se promet explosive sur
kasparov également et toujours les
parties les plus intéressantes dans la
rubrique des positions clés donc bel ami
internaute mercy bay puis eloi merci de
tous ces commentaires à après-demain à
après demain
on
m
bonjour diagonale actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs flash
spécial sarajevo bonjour et loire
bonjour stéphane bonjour à tous alors
samedi enfin lundi pardon c'était donc
un jour de repos donc on reprend
aujourd'hui pour les parties d'hier
bacrot descente aux enfers alors bacrot
tendre très très difficile pour le jeune
étienne le jeune français qui vient de
d'encaisser sa troisième défaite
consécutive et c'est difficile dans un
tournoi nous expliquer ça c'est dur
trois défaites consécutives alors
probablement psychologiquement ça
devient dur puisque tous les tops sont
là en train de s'acharner contre lui
alors effectivement c'est difficile de
lier une jouer contre gourévitch
gourevitch on le met dans n'importe quel
tournoi il fait office de mega favori de
gros loup dans la bergerie
et là on le met à sarajevo et il fait
office de client de joueurs pas très
fort et donc c'est très difficile de
remettre dans le contexte la force de
joueurs sachant que dans le tournoi il
né il fait partie des plus faibles donc
ça c'est difficile ça doit affecter un
peu etienne bacrot il a du mal à jouer
contre des joueurs aussi forts en étant
à 100 % de son énergie
sachant que dans le tournoi le joueur
n'est pas fort enfin bref c'est
compliqué et meetic logiquement gros
problème pour etienne qui perd un peu le
fil et encaisse donc trois défaites de
suite c'est beaucoup et ça va être dur
par ryan a deux qui partent pas le fils
et shirov et caspar enfin si en fait
kasparov sont très forts effectivement
le dira jamais assez
ils sont en tête ils sont vraiment plus
du tournoi hier ils ont fait deux nuls
avec les noirs respectivement contre
shirt morose et mitch donc les deux
leaders tiennent le coup ne seront pas
rattrapés et leur rencontre est
évidemment le moment attendu ce sera
pour après demain probablement she wrote
blanca sport noir la super rencontre
oui ça risque de chauffer chauffer
chauffer dur alors moi aux evil
s'accroche aussi puisque il suit i suis
pas loin alors on va peut-être passer
tout de suite à une première brique pour
voir les positions de notre premier
rubrique donc sur les positions des
parties d'hier alors si on peut lancer
la rubrique les positions clés voilà ça
va pas tarder on peut le faire donc
bon alors allons-y l'anosy pour les
positions clés donc pas de problème nous
lançons la première partie inc